[Music]
nearly one in five couple say money is
their greatest relationship challenge
and more than half disagree on how much
savings they'll actually need to reach
their retirement goals so with so many
couples getting married this year after
a long year of pandemic proposals and
postponed weddings fidelity investments
has a reminder to start forever on the
right financial footing
and yet according to fidelity's 2021
couples in money study while 57 percent
of couples claim they're joint
retirement decision makers more than
half disagree on how much is needed as
we said to reach those goals their
findings also reveal that women need to
get more involved
one in five women still report having
little to no involvement in retirement
planning so our message is it's okay to
delegate but don't abdicate staying
involved in financial decisions really
helps both partners to feel confident
about the future
she says bottom line make money a team
sport she says if you need to make a
weekly financial date night yeah to
discuss your finances and communicate
openly start saving as early as possible
for those newlyweds she says if you're
looking for tips and tools to help you
navigate a whole host of life events you
can go to fidelity.com forward slash
couples